a British newspaper is defending itself
after Prince Harry and his wife Megan
announced legal action against the
tabloid it published a letter that Megan
wrote to her estranged father Harry also
lashed out at the British press for its
treatment of Megan now this comes as a
Duke and Duchess of Sussex wrap up their
Africa tour Debora patta is in
Johannesburg South Africa with more on
this story good morning this is the last
day of official royal engagements in
South Africa with a couple here at this
house meeting grasa Michelle the wife of
former South African president Nelson
Mandela but all that could take a back
seat with the filing of this lawsuit the
timing of the legal action comes as a
surprise after a 10 day African tour
generated a lot of positive publicity
according to royal correspondent Roy
Anika it throws a cloud over the last
day of what was a really really
successful trip for the couple here in
Africa in a stinging reproach to the
media Prince Harry said that they are
suing the tabloid mail on Sunday for
publishing private correspondence from
the Dutchess of Sussex there is a human
cost to this relentless propaganda I
cannot begin to describe how painful it
has been earlier this year the tabloid
newspaper published an article about a
handwritten letter that Megan had sent
to her estranged father Thomas Markham
Harry has accused the paper of editing
the letter selectively in an
intentionally misleading and destructive
way indicating the anger and turmoil he
suffered when his mother Princess Diana
died in a car crash after being pursued
by the paparazzi Harry stated my deepest
fear is history repeating itself I've
seen what happens when someone I love is
commoditized to the point that they are
no longer treated or seen as a real
person I lost my mother and now I watch
my wife falling victim to the same
powerful forces we've had guidance from
the palace that the statement itself was
all Harry's own words even before they
were married Harry accused some
newspapers and social media commentators
of
and sexist reporting of his relationship
with their girlfriend Megan and just
yesterday relationships with the press
grew tense shortly after Harry was asked
a seemingly harmless question by a
journalist while leaving an official
engagement Prince Harry's biographer
says she understands why he wants to
protect his wife but added this seems
like an overly emotional and somewhat
ill-advised outburst it's now up to a
London Court to decide if that is indeed
the case Tony have a remarkable
statement there from Prince Harry thank
you very much it'll be interesting to
see the response in Britain because I've
heard that they've just had it up to
here with how she is relentlessly
attacked but the last line I think says
a lot they're thanking the public for
their continued support it's hugely
appreciated although it may not seem
like it we really need it they both feel
really under attack and as he said he's
worried about what happened to mom yes
happening to Megan that really weighs on
him clearly writing from the heart
exactly